on se bat pour protéger pour sauver
que ce choix par des vidéos des photos
des témoignages presque chaque événement
de la campagne de john médecine se
retrouve sur les réseaux sociaux il faut
parfois un peu de temps pour les
enregistrer le chef adore se mettre
enceinte pour faire passer ses messages
dans le dernier baiser comment est ce
que je peut connecter avec les gens où
ils sont ils sont sur les médias sociaux
sur les réseaux sociaux donc j'essaie
d'utiliser tous les études possibles
pour connecter avec les gens jobs
médecine et filmé sans arrêt par son
équipe chan rachid et productrice au
contenu numérique sur la caravane du npd
elle est toujours à l'affût des segments
vidéo a publié qui s
jobs médecine et naturels et
authentiques c'est ce qui le différencie
des autres chefs sur les médias sociaux
dit elle
le chef du npd à 842 mille abonnés sur
ses comptes twitter et facebook c'est
beaucoup plus que mvno tour yves
françois blanchet et un ami paul réuni
beaucoup moins par contre que justin
trudeau mais ce qui distingue surtout
jobs médecine de ses adversaires c'est
sa grande utilisation des réseaux
favorisée par les jeunes instagram et
surtout secteur dont il est le seul chef
à voir un con qu
il a enregistré cette vidéo avec sa
femme sur le tarmac de l'aéroport de
vancouver au quatrième jour de la
campagne
ce slogan on part se battre pour les
gens a été vu deux millions de fois en
dix jours phénomène assez récent des
réseaux sociaux techtoc permet de
publier de courts montage vidéo de
toutes sortes
je pense que je préfère un petit club
parce que cette façon un peu léger où on
peut aussi ajouter des des profonds et
idées on a besoin d'être tellement
authentique pour utiliser ces
plateformes et pour moi c'est c'est
naturel j'adore ça
mais tik tok avec ses vidéos de 15
secondes a quand même ses limites
c'est sûr que c'est une place pour bâtir
l'image pour battre sur l'image de
chiffres je lâche si j'étais conseillère
politique je l'utiliserai comme ceux
plus que comme une plate-bande passer
des gros message on cherche à voir de la
traction cherche avant de la vider en
cherchant votre cause et c'est ce qui
fait sa force
angelica kabyle aise connaît bien le
conducteur de job médecine qui est suivi
par 7 161 milles personnes ça va
influencer votre vote oui je pense parce
que je comprends plus ce qu'est ce qu'il
veut dire qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire
pour nous comme pas juste pour les
personnes qui sont jugés âgés
a dit m c'est une bonne façon de
rejoindre les jeunes comme moi qui ne
regardent pas les nouvelles dj sino qui
ajoute ensuite qu'elle n'est pas certain
de voter
ce sera un défi du npd qui est populaire
auprès des jeunes les convaincre d'aller
voter devait voter
en 2019 élections canada estime que 54 %
des 18-24 ans et 58 % des 25-34 ans
l'ont fait le taux général de
participation était de 67 % on a vu dans
les dents des dernières années les
jeunes c'est milite pour le climat ce
mini ii contre le racisme systémique
jobs médecine est optimiste et il l'a
fait savoir dans cette publication
victor
vu à ce jour 6 millions 300 mille fois
jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]